hello so tonight I'm gonna share with
you the founding story of TaskRabbit and
some of you may feel like you've heard
the story before but I'm gonna tell you
the story behind the story the true
story of how I found a TaskRabbit it
started on a cold winter night in Boston
was February of 2008 Boston
I remember Miss February because it was
snowing outside and it was really cold
and my husband and I were sitting in our
kitchen and we were getting ready to go
out to dinner so he had called a cab to
pick us up take us across town note that
I said cab not an uber or lyft this is
2008 people and the cab is on its way
when we realized we were out of dog food
at the time we had this hundred pound
yellow lab named Kobe who we kept very
well fed and we thought oh no how are we
gonna get this dog food are we really
gonna have the cab stop on the way to
the restaurant are we gonna drag the dog
food with us the restaurant on what if
all the stores are closed on the way
home why is this such a big problem it's
dog food it should be simple and that
way the conversation turned into
wouldn't it be nice if there was just a
place online we could go say we need a
dog food name the price who are willing
to pay we're certain there was probably
someone online that could help us out
maybe someone in the neighborhood maybe
someone who is at the store at that very
second why couldn't we just connect with
them so my husband's also in technology
so we always had these very geeky
conversations in the house and I grabbed
my iPhone at the
it had just come out four months earlier
this is the dark ages you know no one
was really using location-based
awareness yet in their apps
no one was building on mobile no one is
building on the iPhone there was no App
Store no one was using the social graph
social networking Facebook was just
coming out of the college scene but how
was an engineer and I worked at IBM for
eight years and I love technology and my
husband Kevin was the same way and so I
became really passionate and really
excited that evening about what if we
mashed up these technologies you know
that the iPhone and mobile and location
and social and what if we were able to
connect real people in the real world to
get real things done like is that kind
of insane and so I grabbed my phone and
I said all right such a site existed
what would it be called
and at the time the first thing that
came to mind was run my errand
and the domain was available domains are
never available so I bought the domain
name for $6.99 and on the spot that
night 20 minutes later I hated the name
but I thought you know what maybe maybe
I should see if there's something here
before I obsess over the name so the the
cab came to pick us up and I gave Kobe
lots of extra treats and threw him some
some chicken I think we had in the
fridge so he didn't starve that night
but um over margaritas and Mexican food
we've sort of started talking about this
idea that evolved into TaskRabbit that
was a pretty crazy magnet because by the
end of the by then at that dinner we're
meeting a bunch of friends we had a
business plan for business plan for
TaskRabbit
and someone vomited in myself too
so it was like one of those just like
crazy nights right but we woke up the
next morning and we're like hey do you
remember that idea we had like my domain
name but I bought run my own life do we
really think that's still a thing and
even in the light of day the following
decade it seemed like a good idea so
four months later I quit my job at IBM
to build the first version of the site
and get it launched in Boston now that's
the family the story for TaskRabbit but
how do they actually found
TaskRabbit I believe that ideas are not
inventions I believe they're discoveries
and I think our job as an entrepreneur
is to be able to discover those ideas
because they're all around us
they're like air we breathe them in we
breathe them out and we have to be able
to uncover them so the real story about
family TaskRabbit isn't that I came up
with this idea sure there's this moment
of inspiration Kobe was out of dog food
one night in the timing was great
because these technologies were coming
into play and I thought about how we
could mash him up together but really it
came down to how was i training myself
to think entrepreneurially at that time
the truth is is that leading up to that
night leading up to that moment of
inspiration I had been obsessing for
months about leaving my job at IBM I was
kind of bored and I was thinking there's
got to be other things that I could be
doing I was already starting to think
entrepreneurially and I was in a certain
mindset and I think as I look back that
was the key if I hadn't been in that
entrepreneurial mindset when that moment
of the inspiration hit when we were out
of dog food I never
discovered the idea for TaskRabbit one
of my friends Adam grant has this
amazing book called originals Feliz some
of you have read it if not I highly
recommend it's awesome and in it he
describes this concept of a day now
Lucia day is the opposite of deja vu
so you know deja vu is when you see
something for the first time but you
feel like you've seen it before like
you've been there before can be
explained as a simple glitch in the
matrix but boota boota de is the
opposite of that it's when you've seen
something a thousand times and you're
able to take a step back and look at it
differently and that's what I did that
night when we were out of dog food I
confess it was not the first time we had
run out of dog food for a portico be
delinquent doggy parents now I have two
children and I promise you they eat
every single day but it was really about
how do i how did I get into that
entrepreneur mindset and I was actually
talking with Adam about this exact
things I said you know what I just that
concept in your book really resonated
with me because I felt like that being
out of dog food that inspiration that
night that was a vuja de moment and he's
like yeah but how did you get into that
moment how did you why did your brain
lead you there and so I took a step back
and I thought about it and I said you
know what the truth is is for months I
had been thinking about different ideas
and trying to look at the world
differently and not going on autopilot
sometimes it's so easy to just go
through your life on autopilot you have
your routines you hit challenges you
kind of move through them but if you can
take a step back and you can slow
yourself down that's when you can really
start to see things differently now for
me getting into this entrepreneurial
mindset felt a little bit awkward at
first I mean I was I was going through
you know normal things everyday but
stopping and talking incessantly about
them and asking my husband Kevin what he
thought you know it can feel really
awkward but if you can force yourself to
get there and I think it can be a really
really powerful thing you can take the
ordinary and turn it into something
extraordinary so how did I take this
idea for TaskRabbit and raise my first
round of funding and turn it into you
know where we are today well I had the
idea quit my job at IBM build the first
version of the siding got it launched in
Boston now what it's September of 2008
the stock market is crashing very tough
economic time worse time to be raising
money by the way I didn't even know how
to raise money at the time but I got
accepted into an incubator program and
that brought me out here to the Bay Area
called FB fund and it was run by
Facebook and dave McClure before he did
500 startups started this incubator and
so I was flying back and forth between
Boston and San Francisco a week in
Boston a week in San Francisco
completely bootstrapping the company on
my own and I flew to Boston and had just
spent the week in San Francisco and got
an email from Dave saying hey we have a
special guest
come into the office on Monday this is
Friday his name is Tim Ferriss and he's
willing to meet with companies that are
here yes oh man I just flew back from
San Francisco and I'm in Boston and I'm
supposed to spend this week in Boston
and actually this company is live in
Boston there's no one else but me like
running this thing right now so I go
online and I look at plane tickets and I
see that it's like 750 dollars to get a
ticket back out to San Francisco that's
Sunday night and be there for Monday and
I emailed Dave and I was like hey I'm
not supposed to be in town but this
sounds really exciting you know how much
time are we gonna have with Tim he's
like you have 15 minutes 15 minutes with
him okay so $750 15 minutes with Tim
Ferriss like is this really worth it
like I'm this is going on my credit card
um I don't know if I should do this or
not but I thought you know what if I can
turn $750 into the million dollar seed
ruined
that I'm with hoping to raise then it'll
be worth it and that was my threshold I
was like anything less than that is not
worth it and simple I bought the plane
ticket I got on the plane I flew to San
Francisco met with Tim for 15 minutes
that Monday and I said all right my goal
is to get him on as an advisor because I
think he could really help us and his
book the 4-hour workweek had just come
out and he writes all about living
efficiently and TaskRabbit is like the
perfect thing that fits in his portfolio
and so I thought in 15 minutes I'm not
going to convince him to come on as an
advisor but I could definitely get a
second meeting so that's my goal and 15
minutes just get a second meeting so
walking to the Facebook office you know
get the meeting with Tim sit down with
him start showing him at the time it was
still actually run my errand calm showed
him aside and you know it's like 10
minutes 11 minutes 12 minutes he's
talking and I'm like oh my god it's
almost 15 minutes and I haven't been
able to ask you for a sec
meeting yet and so gets to 15 minutes
and I was like you know what um this has
been so helpful you know can we meet
again would you be willing to spend more
time with me and he's sort of hesitated
because he's like saw the crazy look in
my eye you know what you can email my
admin and she'll set something up so
walked out of the room and immediately
you know email this admin and she said
you know what Tim actually you know can
do a call with you next week and I Sai
called me in a phone call I just met him
in person like I feel like I'm better in
person and I've got to turn this plane
ticket into a million dollar seed round
how am I gonna do this and so I said you
know what I'm gonna be in San Francisco
at that time in the neighborhood ended
up meeting Tim in person over lunch
we've really hit it off and at the end
of that lunch he agreed to come on as an
advisor and he is the one that
introduced me to an Morocco from
floodgate fun to lead our 1 million
dollar seed round but I made it happen
and I think for me the biggest takeaways
from that first year of discovering
TaskRabbit and raising that money was
ideas are everywhere I needed to be in
the right mindset to find that idea and
then just willing your way forward
willing things to happen there was no
way I was gonna let that plane ticket
not turn in to that seed round of
funding thank you
[Applause]